you dare show your face yesterday
how you doing Daddy I'm all right Mama
yep I am your cool Daddy hi you
look guilty I
fear I may have daddied us a little too
close to the Sun you just daddy does too
hard I think I did you can never I think
I I can do I can do this I have a
straightforward not unhinged interview
with you what was uninjed about that
aside from my 102 degree temperature
no I didn't but you posted about that I
was like wait a minute I know I'm sorry
it's okay
it was post contagiousness yeah
fine I don't know I had to be there what
is the meaning of life exactly let's
talk about that let's talk about that
now
because I can have a serious interview I
can do this I can say I can we can be
normal okay
what does it all mean
I'll tell you tell me I don't know
and I don't think we're supposed to
um
and that's
the meaning of life
thank you for joining us
um you can find us chatting but we will
continue to be continued for the carpet
tomorrow yes we'll be back after these
messages
[Applause]
you're reunited with brogo
yes babies you guys are back together
some call them grogu some say baby Yoda
do you have your own nickname
for a little man
I do now I can't keep doing this what
this is fantastic I actually I can't I I
have to choose little man little man
yeah I like that
how does it feel to be back together it
feels good
um it feels wonderful I think it's gonna
feel even more wonderful for the
audience uh that's going to be watching
season three
um you know it's such a disarming
dynamic in the instant
um uh that they meet it just works this
armored from head to toe uh reluctant
Stony figure and this vulnerable but
powerful adorable creature but
um the way that a parent-child
relationship can develop and how those
Dynamics can shift and who's learning
from who who's protecting who who's
saving who is is is something a little
bit more up for grabs and he has his
little chain email now I know it's so
cute isn't it so cute they're so smart I
can't stand it listen to me
trying to sound like an intellectual and
now we're back to adorability which is
where we need to be which is where we
need to be
there's nothing and where we need to
stay and there's nothing wrong with it
okay people is that a crime
um why is Moth getting so mean
ask him he's such a jerk I know
um what's his problem he's so mean to me
right he wants that power
he does he wants that little man power
little man Little Man the end of every
episode of the first
episode of a new season of Mandalorian
has like some kind of shocker we have
we've had the child and we're like oh my
gosh Boba Fett's alive show me your face
of how you reacted to the end of this
first episode you read the script you go
the first episode of season three season
three
um I was like
yeah
there you have it that's perfect
now I know season four is already
written how long do you see yourself
playing the Mandalorian do you feel like
you're you could do it forever as long
as they keep writing it
or you know
um
give give me let me write it no no no no
I don't want to take it away from them
just that as long as they keep writing
it and um even if I can't fit into the
suit somebody can
[Laughter]
I just gotta do the voice
mythosaurs extinct from the world of
Star Wars yeah because they're like
supposedly it's extinct but hmm I think
um you think that they're in the Living
Waters of mandolin you're all into the
conspiracy theories is that a conspiracy
theory the that that myth is well it's
something that the mandalorians believe
[Music]
it's not gonna work okay okay it's not
okay locked
vault Vault Vault hmm jet lag
um I love you I love your energy thank
you
laughs